I am eating my feelings this is a very
depressing show today I have pizza I'm
gonna eat this was not part of the plan
that I would be to drink talk about
[Music]
eating in front of a huge audience
is usually what Eli Manning does why are
so many of you watched these videos
there's good TV out there not on this
channel but out there the guy whooping
into his noodles is Nick ekkada avocado
and he's a mukbang her that sentence was
barely English Mikado avocados not his
real name but I loved it so I'm gonna
say Nick out of avocado as much as
possible Nick ekkada avocado maybe he
calls himself Nick Akkad Oh avocado
because his body is turning into one
mukbang is where lonely people make
videos of themselves eating disgusting
amounts of disgusting food and then even
lonelier people watch them what makes
Nick a kado avocado special is that he
sobs over every meal which comes in
handy if you don't have a salt shaker if
I want to see a depressed guy slowly
kill himself by gorging on weird food
I'd watch Anthony Bourdain yeah stop
with the new episode CNN but I don't
need to exploit a man's death for
ratings so before we lose Nick DeCarlo
avocados diabetes I flew Nick Accardo
avocado to LA where everybody watches
what they eat for this week's
ce-web-rity profile
hey Daniel moly guacamole nice to meet
you nice to meet you Thanks for meeting
me at the complimentary Hampton Inn
breakfast buffet are you staying here oh
that's what these robes are for you know
I don't think we're supposed to be
sitting at the buffet
why because you don't sit at the Buffett
buffets a bar you can sit at a bar I
guess but why do we have to be here so
early because that's when the buffet is
at its hottest that's hamptonality
accuse some torx there you go all right
where are you from I'm from Columbia are
you really from Columbia no no I I live
there with my husband hold on me have to
try some of these eggs explain to me
what muck banging is it's actually
mukbang it comes from Korea that sounds
racist no Martin you say it like it's
kind of Rachel I'm saying how they
pronounce it mom like if you go to
France you say I'm in France you don't
say for all so if I'm in China I think
so mark Bonin the word means eating
broadcasts the idea was that they put
their camera down they filmed themselves
eating and then other people would eat
with them when you dirt off it seems
sexual some people do that but that's
not my target audience you're getting
millions of views I know but not for
masturbators do you want syrup okay okay
sure that's plenty of Sirk you didn't
have to syrup the tongs I
noticed in the beginning of your videos
you look a little bit smaller it's nice
to be here I'm gonna be doing this alone
already you know oh yeah I've gained
like 50 pounds this isn't healthy I know
it's not the way to do this what about
the amount of food why is it so much
well I mean it doesn't have to be a lot
but I like to eat a lot just cuz no but
you're eating an unhealthy amount you
wouldn't eat that much in a normal city
mom no no no no right so why are you
doing it that amount of food because
it's a great excuse to get fat
how many videos are you posting a week I
post like five days a week five mukbang
sessions a week you're gonna die no
you're gonna fall right you're literally
getting full already you would never be
able to do this no I wouldn't I would be
for like the premature ejaculator muck
bangers you know hi we're you the food
sweater by the way why are you always
crying in your videos you are you that
emotional I am well the food doesn't
help either Oh cuz you just feel gross
well you feel like but then also
like you're just it throws your hormones
out of whack and I'm already really
emotional so I just sometimes I cry what
was wrong with that alfredo pizza you
were eating the one in Colombia yeah I
was big and it was flat she's looked
hard was i crying yeah of course you're
crying it tastes better than it looked
hey let me grab one of those yes yeah
that's raw waffle batter isn't that bad
for you this was a waffle smoothie tell
me about how this has affected your
poops are they enormous yes but people
think I all the time well I just a
mukbang how long after one of your
videos before uh oh it's usually a media
it's immediate yeah and it's not the
food I'm eating it's whatever's there
that gets pushed down is it diarrhea is
it solid if I eat something that's
really really spicy then that hurts yeah
you said your bottle bleeds a lot it
doesn't bleed but it hurts these fire
noodles I'm obsessed with they really
make my a-hole bleed loudly just sting
sing like a wasp why fire noodles
they're popular running low on eggs here
if it wasn't popular the Korean fire
noodle challenge I would not be on the
toilet crying twice a week good eggs are
on the bottom
what's up with a bird you shouldn't let
your bird eat that food that's bad for
them I know but his name's mr. noodle
just cuz his name is mr. noodle doesn't
mean you should eat noodles okay you
caught me
no one is gonna tell you that feeding
your bird hot noodles is a good idea
well you know they can't feel spice
thank you they don't have spice
receptors I didn't know that yeah
everybody go ahead and feed them why do
you get hot sauce in your eyes so much I
have no idea why that happens I'm just
doing my video and hot sauce splatters
into my eyeball you want me to tell you
why it's happening why you've been sit
so low but if you had a taller chair
maybe your eyes would be out of harm's
way
I don't know I think I need to get
goggles from now on can I pass me the
orange juice please
how long have you been married
um a year and a half you still kiss if
you skip that tell me guys what is this
a mukbang gangbang easy spitfyre buddy
and some of these these pancakes already
got syrup on them I think I'm doing the
heavy lifting for us real piece of
you seem to be riddled with diseases but
they're all self diagnosed so I'm
calling don't worry switch pain
go to a doctor cuz have a phobia you
said in your videos that you have
chronic coughing syndrome diabetes
kidney failure okay I thought I had
kidney failure I actually turned out not
to okay and I thought that I had
diabetes I actually turned out not to to
you eat that uh the way that durian
fruit oh I love dirt that smells like
assholes it does actually my best friend
used to say it smells like Indian food
wrapped in a diaper
it looks like a pastry on camera
they thought it was dough it's so good
what's it what's a texture like it's
kind of like scrambled eggs is there any
danger outside of just unhealthy eating
there's a lot of haters actually that's
one the sole reasons as to why I have a
lot of issues like they really get to me
of course they did you have haters right
hmm what makes you sad today I don't
know I just
sometimes when I'm done a mukbang I feel
full and then I just I think about all
the stuff in my life and I get are you
gonna cry no maybe
you wanna hug it out
[Music]
break it up boys it's 10:00 a.m.
breakfast is over but we're still mud
bogging it's okay I brought to go boxes
all right Nick yukata avocado
let's go rinse off in the pool all right
we ate each other's boxes then took the
courtesy shuttle to the mall that's
hamptonality one of these days camping
in is gonna have to pony up for all
these free plugs